uh we finally found one of these
so-called dead voters from the 2020
election turns out it was a republican
voting under the name of his deceased
wife this has been one of the stories
this is one of the stories we've been
told now for a very long time but it
really scaled up with the November of
2020 election dead people are voting now
not literally dead people people who are
dead are showing up as having voted and
this is clearly some kind of major fraud
being perpetrated it's part of the theft
of the election by Joe Biden from Donald
Trump now before even analyzing and
before telling you about the story and
before analyzing the broader data around
dead people voting
it should be mentioned that even if
their claims were true of widespread
dead people voting they would also have
to show and prove that it's happening in
a way that helped Joe Biden and hurt
Donald Trump you could have ten thousand
so-called dead people voting but if it
was five thousand dead people voting for
Trump and five thousand dead people
voting for Biden it doesn't actually
make a difference in the election so
absent from many of these discussions is
okay part one is is it true but part two
if true is it happening in a partisan
way where it would actually help one
candidate rather than the other the
answer to all of the above is it's not
actually happening and we're going to
get to that in a second but as is often
the case with these stories the side
shouting about the supposed fraud in
this case dead people voting is the only
side that's getting caught doing it this
is a story out of Nevada
we previously mentioned this to you in a
list of examples of Republicans doing
this he has now been sentenced Nevada
man who voted twice using dead wife's
ballot sentenced to probation and fined
two thousand dollars this is Donald Kirk
hartle who has accepted a plea deal to
avoid jail time a judge on Tuesday
sentenced the Las Vegas man to probation
on a charge he voted twice in the 2020
election by mailing in his deceased
wife's ballot the i-team was first to
report that Kirk hartle 55 years old was
facing two charges relating to last
year's election in court Tuesday hartle
pleaded guilty to one charge of voting
more than once in the same election he
appeared virtually in court he was also
fined two grand as part of the plea
agreement the original category D Felony
carried a maximum prison sentence of
four years gets probation and two grand
ultimately to me this seems like a cheap
political stunt that backfired and shows
our voting system actually works because
you were ultimately caught that's what
his uh that's what the judge in the case
said
uh Rosemary hartle died in 2017 at age
52 from breast cancer kirkhardle
um is a surviving husband a ballot for
Rosemary was issued in October and was
received by the county but Kirk said the
ballot never came to his house the
i-team found that even though Rosemary
died in 2017 her name appeared on the
active voter list Kirk hartle says I
would like to say I accept full
responsibility for my actions and regret
them and I'm thankful for your
consideration so we finally found the
dead people voting and it was a
republican now this is an opportunity to
remind you first of all there are people
writing to me saying the punishment
should have been far stricter should
have been much much stricter punishment
here uh for this guy okay that's
something that can be talked about we
have data we have done there have been
very good investigations done into
so-called dead people voting and it
turns out that it's really easy and
popular to say ten thousand people
twenty thousand thirty thousand
suspected dead voters the BBC actually
investigated this uh there was an
initial claim from Republicans that for
example in Michigan 10 000 dead people
voted they had this list of ten thousand
people that were dead uh the BBC did
something very interesting they said
okay from the ten thousand let's pick a
random 30. let's just take 30 names at
random and they started going through
the 30 names in fact they did 31 names
out of the 31 they spoke to 11 of the
people
and we're able to confirm they're still
alive so Random group of 31 supposedly
dead voters 11 are just straight up
still alive
they found another 17 they weren't able
to speak to them but there was no record
of their death there was no obituary
there was no record anywhere that said
these people have died
um and uh were able to find although
they didn't speak to them evidence that
they were alive either records or other
interactions with the public or
government system so that got them to 28
and then they found three people who
were dead they were dead at the time
that they checked when they looked into
it the three people were two of the
three were alive at the time that they
voted meaning they didn't do anything
wrong okay you could say well two of the
people died since sending their ballot
shouldn't be counted you can look at
that
and then one the last one
um was a an error where a Junior's vote
was counted as the senior imagine you
know David packman Jr although Jews
don't do the junior thing Imagine David
pack Imagine David Pacman senior is dead
David Pacman Jr is alive and votes and
the vote is counted wrongly as if it was
David pakman senior still only one vote
right it was counted as the wrong person
but it's still only one vote that's what
was found when BBC actually investigated
this so don't fall for the fact that
it's happening when it's not and more
importantly even if they were able to
prove that it's happening they would
also have to prove that it's happening
in a partisan way such that it would
actually help one candidate to feed
another in even a single state which
they've not recognized
one of our sponsors is kamikoto making
elegant high-end beautiful Japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from Honshu Japan I've been a
big fan of Japanese kitchen knives for a
long time they have some great
advantages when you look closely at a
kamikoto knife you see the quality of
the iron work they only use Japanese
steel every knife comes in a perfect
heavy duty Ash wood box makes storage
really easy it looks great in your
kitchen or drawer the balance of the
knives is just amazing I've been using
them for everything every knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee on their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at Michelin star restaurants who
use kamikota and through this
partnership they're doing with us
kamikoto is giving you 50 off on top of
their other special offers just go to
kamikodo.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for fifty dollars off the link is
down below